hello welcome to this session on
innovating with transformative databases
for an always on digital world
my name is sylesh krishnan murphy and i
lead engineering for cloud native
databases at google today i'm thrilled
to have hari ramamurthy who's a
technology fellow at the home depot join
us
hari will share how the home depot uses
google's cloud native databases to
transform their business in the modern
digital world
we'll begin today by talking about
transformative capabilities and why they
are so important
next we'll review our transformative
databases spanner bigtable and firestore
and the new innovations we are bringing
to this portfolio
and then we'll hear from hari on how the
home depot uses these databases
today's innovators are disrupting
traditional industries by using data and
software to deliver personalized and
seamless digital experiences across
devices and channels modern conveniences
like buy online pickup and store
instant digital payments real-time ride
sharing requests and other marketplace
services have raised the bar in consumer
experiences in respect of the size and
complexity of the problem or even how
regulated the industry is
these disruptive experiences require
sophisticated and complex applications
that need to serve millions of users in
a revival and continuously available
fashion
scalably handle viral growth and
unpredictable spikes in demand without
missing a beat
and securely deal with bad actors and
comply with stringent regulatory regimes
speed is critical and you need the
flexibility to iterate quickly and
deliver innovative and differentiated
experiences for your customers
the key to scalably and securely serving
millions of users
is an operational database that will
power your applications and run your
business
you need databases with transformative
capabilities and the new table stakes
are an availability sla of five nines
with zero maintenance downtime and
automatic failure recovery it's about
five minutes of downtime every year
online and unlimited scaling
and zero touch global and multi-region
deployments
most important the highest security
complying with the industry's most
demanding standards
at google cloud we offer not one but
three transformative databases that
provide the capabilities that you need
to deliver innovative customer
experiences these are spanner bigtable
and firestore and through these
databases you get to access the very
same groundbreaking technologies that
power the google apps that we all love
and use every day
search youtube gmail maps each of these
are used by billions of users worldwide
and while data is born in operational
databases these are only the first part
of a bigger journey
our database services are deeply
integrated with a larger ecosystem of
market leading data and ai services that
are part of google cloud these include
services like bigquery gke data flow
data stream pub sub cloud functions and
so on
and these services help you break down
your operational silos build data
pipelines generate real-time insights
and make better business decisions
in 2021 we delivered many new features
and enhancements across the entire
portfolio
some of the more notable ones include
customer managed encryption keys data
access audit logging key visualizers for
observability and an availability sla of
up to five nines for big table matching
that of spanner and firestore
and today we are excited to share how we
are raising the bar yet again with more
new innovations
let's take a closer look
spanner is a fully managed relational
database with global scale asset
transactions and full sql support strong
consistency across regions and
continents
high availability up to five nines with
zero scheduled downtime
to give you a sense of the magnitude of
its scale spanner processes over a
billion requests per second a week
there's never ever been a relational
database with the scale of spam
and now we want to democratize panel and
make it available to everyone
earlier this year we announced granular
instance sizing which is available in
preview and works based on a new concept
of processing units or pus
a node is made of a thousand pus and you
can now get started by provisioning 100
pus you can still scale up in steps of
100 views without any downtime
going from 100 200 300 all the way to
1000 pu's which is one node
you can then scale out by adding
capacity in increments of a thousand pus
thousand two thousand three thousand or
a node at a time
with granular instance configurations
you will be able to provision one tenth
of a current node or one tenth the price
and can now get started with spammer for
just 65 dollars a month
we think this is a game changer for
customers who need smaller instances for
smaller and medium-sized workloads and
also unlocks creativity and innovation
for smaller teams on tight budgets
postgresql has emerged today as the de
facto industry standard for relational
databases as businesses accelerate to
the cloud
and today i am excited to announce cloud
spanner's postgres interface which
further democratizes access to spanner
for millions of developers and isps
this interface combines the power and
reliability of spanner with the
familiarity and portability of hostplus
with the postgres interface enterprises
looking to standardize on postgres can
now take advantage of spanner's global
scale five nines availability and strong
consistency using the skills and tools
from the popular and ubiquitous
postpress ecosystem
spanner's postgres interface is now
available in preview and we'd love your
feedback if you're interested please
sign up on the url listed on the slide
bigtable is a fully managed scalable
nosql database for large operational and
analytical workloads with an
industry-leading availability sla of up
to five nines
it's ideal for apps that require
consistent single-digit millisecond
latencies and need to support high
throughput millions of requests per
second
bigtable scales seamlessly from your
first gigabyte to petabyte scale and in
fact bigtable has more than 10 exabytes
of data under management it also
integrates with the apache ecosystem and
supports the hbase api
and today i'm excited to share that auto
scaling is coming soon to big table with
auto scaling bigtable will automatically
add or remove capacity in response to
the changing demands of your workloads
so you only pay for the capacity that
you need
auto scaling reduces management overhead
as your teams can now spend more time on
your business and less time managing
your infrastructure
also doubled the storage limits for
bigtable so you can now store more data
cheaply
big table nodes now support twice as
much storage capacity from ssd you go
from a limit of two and a half terabytes
per node to a maximum of five terabytes
per node and for hdd from eight
terabytes per node to a maximum of 16
terabytes per node this is especially
more cost effective for batch workloads
that operate on large amounts of data
firestore is our fully managed scalable
and truly serverless document database
that lets you easily and rapidly develop
rich mobile and web applications
all this with an availability sla of up
to five nines that's achieved through
strongly consistent data replication
developers love firestore because of its
ability to serve both as a document
database and as a backend as a service
it's therefore no surprise that firestar
has built a thriving developer community
with more than 250 000 monthly active
developers and five-star apps powering
more than
750 million monthly active end users
using firebase auth
you can develop and deploy apps fast
with direct connectivity to the database
no middle tier needed these apps can
have rich and collaborative experiences
with built-in real-time light
synchronization across devices as well
as seamless support for disconnected or
offline mode
firestore's developer experience truly
sets it apart and we continue to invest
heavily in this area
with key visualizer customers can
quickly and visually identify
performance issues
with the latest version of our web sdk
we've added free shaking which reduces
the sdk footprint by as much as 80
percent the smaller sdk means faster
load time for your app
both key visualizer and the new web sdk
are available today
we'll also graduate the unity and c plus
sdks to general availability in q4
both of these sdks make it easier to
develop mobile games using firestore
we're excited about mobile gaming as
game developers have told us how
firestore lets them quickly build and
iterate on their games
in addition to developer friendliness
we've been focused on making firestorm
more enterprise friendly with a strong
commitment to security and privacy
data access audit logs in preview lets
privileged administrators audit all
operations admin and data on a firestore
database
custom iim in ga lets you align file
store permissions to your organization's
im roles
in addition to these enhancements i am
excited to announce new features
with vpc service controls customers will
be able to reduce exfiltration risks
through network level security controls
that include firestore in a security
param perimeter
and with app check customers will be
able to ensure only signed and
pre-authorized apps are allowed to make
requests to firestone
we'll roll out previews for vtc service
controls and app check in q4
let's now take a look at real-world
examples and hear from hari on how the
home depot is using these transmitted
databases for a variety of use cases
thank you spanish
home depot is the largest home
improvement retailer in the us with
close to 2 000 stores
in the us
but specifically in the context of
this last year that's been so
unprecedented
the amount of stress that we've been
placing on all our id systems in general
has has really been significant and
thanks to
the google platform overall and many of
these databases i think our systems have
actually come out doing quite well
during these really challenging times
some of the key metrics if you really
look at it in the in the course of this
uh really extraordinary period that we
are in uh we're really
we're delighted that we grew our
business in 2020 by 21 billion dollars
86 percent
of uh
the digital sales growth
and over 3.6 billion visits to our
website are some of the key metrics that
underscore the criticality of the
technology platforms and solutions that
uh you know we've been running through
this
period
let's look at cloud spanner and its
usage in some more uh detail
there are multiple scenarios uh in the
organization especially in areas like
supply chain or order management or
loyalty
where it is really critical
that
the system state moves from one
atomic acid compliant state to
another uh you know consistent
transactional state
and we need to do this in addition to
those systems actually being available
in multiple data centers and serving
traffic coming from various regions uh
to
these uh apis and the on the databases
that power them and this is really where
spanner has uh you know been a key
player in ensuring that we're meeting
the level of
service that is expected of
our customers
to look at spanner in
some more detail i i think the fact that
we in these areas are able to deploy our
software on three or more data centers
and have really large volumes of data i
mean the 10 td is still you know where
we are currently and we see that growing
rapidly
but
be able to serve the traffic that's
coming through in multiple data centers
and have the system
move from that one consistent
transactional state to another has been
really
key in making sure that
we are
always
not only serving traffic at extremely
high volumes but
we do not have to do it with any fear
about the consistency with which the
system is actually performing
in addition
capabilities like a secondary indices
has been really helpful in some of these
scenarios in making sure that we can
access the data and
reach the the appropriate pattern of
usage uh you know depending on the
context the fact that we are
fundamentally able to deploy these
applications that have strong
consistency guarantees
without needing to worry about uptime
and be able to serve our customers in
these various geographical zones has
really been a game changer for us and is
something that
you know we've been really excited to
use and employ as part of our overall
strategy
on the other side of the spectrum there
are also multiple scenarios where we may
not need the strong consistency
guarantees but we have extremely
demanding requirements with regards to
the response time of the database as
well as the scale of the database and
this is really where bigtable has been a
game changer for us
a specific case in point is on the
website where we employ uh personalized
uh experiences for our customers we've
been able to tailor these experiences at
extremely high volumes based on the
journey that the customer has taken
combine it with prior purchase history
as well as both static and dynamic rules
that we've actually learned based on
customer shopping behaviors and some of
these requirements demand that we easily
scale up to thousands of transactions
per second and we've been able to do
that quite effortlessly with a big table
in addition there are scenarios like
inventory aggregation where we really
have to bring together
the inventory picture across our
network both the stores and the supply
chain and be able to do this in a matter
of milliseconds so that we are able to
appropriately promise to our customers
the inventory that's available in
various uh locations and
we're really glad that you know we chose
bigtable as as the platform you know to
build some of these experiences
i think it's not worthy that
in many of these scenarios we are
dealing with
certainly uh thousands of transactions
per second during regular processes but
in scenarios like the recommendations
there are scenarios where we need to
process certain batch processes that may
push up the databases transaction
throughput to up to
450 000 transactions per second and we
do this on a consistent basis for short
periods of time without needing to
employ
a large cluster throughout the period
but rather just bringing up the
the increased number of nodes when we
need it and then going back to a more
regular size cluster
as as mentioned here currently that's
typically from a 10 to up to 30 nodes
and and you know we're really excited
about
having this type of elasticity come
to play
in in addition the fact that we're able
to serve these extremely high volumes of
uh traffic without having to worry about
maintaining these databases worrying
about
updates and be able to do it in that
multi-data center setup that is
almost necessary for our scales and
volumes
has been uh you know truly a game
changer and has allowed us to deal with
the type of spikes that we have seen
through the course of this last year
firestore is another really interesting
databases
database that we're doing some
prototypes with and a specific
capability of firestore with its offline
capabilities both from a read as well as
from
a right through cash standpoint is
something that's of great interest and
there are certain scenarios uh across
our stores in home where we really
believe that this capability
could come in really handy and we're
currently in the process of prototyping
this
database and you know we're really
excited by what it has to offer
thank you hari for sharing how the home
depot is innovating customer experiences
with google cloud databases and driving
the growth of your business in this very
challenging
and interesting time for all of us
google cloud databases provide a
groundbreaking platform for innovation
based on decades of our own first-hand
experiences with shaping the digital
world we offer the highest levels of
availability reliability and global
scale
enabling you to deliver the best
possible experiences for your customers
there is tons more exciting content at
next and i encourage you all to attend
these sessions to learn more about
spanner bigtable and firestore to dive
deeper take the quick lapse
thank you all so much for your time
today